I don't often get into a fight but when
I do I want to win it's hard because
everyone knows who she is and what she
looks like
it's harder than playing someone who's
imaginary and yes the reserved side of
it is not something that's very natural
to me it is my duty as Queen I think she
um is just a woman and a mother and a
wife and a daughter and also happens to
be the queen of England I thought there
is anyone who knows the British people
more than I do I was terrified I was
very very
intimidated I mean
the fact I had to find an impersonation
of her that was believable and and
people would accept that I sounded and
looked like her we have all been trying
in our different ways to cope so what I
say to you now I say from my heart I did
a lot of research there was this
personality that started revealing
itself to me who was honest and decent
and fun-loving
and warm above all responsible to her
Duty as the Monarch and everything else
had to take second place to that
including her family in 2006 Helen
Mirren gave an oscar-worthy performance
of her majesty in the queen a drama
following the aftermath of Princess
Diana's death I met the queen very
briefly and she was absolutely charming
and twinkly and sweet and I tried to get
that Queen into my interpretation Helen
pay tribute to Elizabeth saying we mourn
a woman who with or without the crown
was the epitome of nobility I can see
that the world has changed
and one must
modernize arise so all sin Powers get us
away from that lunatic wonderful over
the years many actors have taken on the
role of her highness including Emma
Thompson who recreated the Queen's
encounter with the Buckingham Palace
Intruder in walking the dogs I wanted
someone to talk to
and I thought I bet she'd listen
listening is part of my job Nev Campbell
was Princess Elizabeth Who falls for
Winston Churchill played by Christian
Slater in the parody Churchill the
Hollywood years Kristin Scott Thomas was
the queen on Broadway and in 2011 the
queen even got animated in Cars 2 voiced
by Vanessa Redgrave I hereby dub the
portrayed the Monarch early in her reign
in season one of the crown in 2016 which
highlighted the changing Dynamics in her
marriage to Prince Villa it's very much
about the the encroaching outside world
I think on the family and on her there's
great love there and great affection and
great respect but it's it's all the time
uh coupled with her duty to the crown
and her loyalty to the crown they are
genuinely trying to have a relationship
and a marriage and at every turn they're
sort of thwarted and it's just really
really difficult Olivia Coleman took the
throne next on the Netflix hit the
expectations of the queen are so big
how's that been Queen Elizabeth
everybody knows you know her hair it's
only one woman in the world without
hairdo Imelda Stanton is set to wear the
crown in season five dropping this
November production was suspended in the
Queen's honor and Olivia paid tribute
saying she made a promise as a young
woman and she absolutely kept it with
such dignity were all incredibly
impressed by what she did it's very very
easy to see us just strong but I think
she's many many other things I think
she's very very vulnerable and there's a
strength there but she doesn't see that
as equality in herself I don't think
people do when real strength real
fortitude and kind of endurance people
don't really believe that they have it
but they do and they just get on with it
and that generation was very light but
anyway they were very Keep Calm and
Carry On
foreign